ils ont repris le travail ce matin sans
illusion les salariés du site
d'hérimoncourt ne travailleront bientôt
plus ici l'activité de recyclage des
moteurs sera transférée à vesoul à 80 km
la direction de psa s'engagent à
reclasser l'ensemble du personnel à
vesoul mulhouse où sochaux tout proche
c'est un sentiment de tristesse parce
qu'on tenait à notre emploi sur le site
et du coup il va falloir changer nos
habitudes parce que pour la direction
c'est presque une opportunité une chance
nous on ne le vois pas du tout comme ça
parce que changer de changer de site
changer de travail ce n'est pas une
chance on était bien ici ce que j'ai
mais l'idéal on a notre coeur de métier
qu'il soit ici sur les bons cours
sochaux n'a rien à voir avec nous c'est
pas n'est pas dans les métiers et
malheureusement ça va être difficile
pour les gens maintenant forcément c'est
plus près donc oui on peut dire que
c'est plus avantageux pour hérimoncourt
berceau de la famille peugeot
la fermeture annoncée de l'usiné est un
traumatisme
psa s'est engagé auprès des syndicats à
chercher d'éventuels repreneurs à même
de réindustrialiser le site historique
il ya 200 emplois qui vont partir sur de
la commune d'ici 2020 maintenant la
question que je pose à psa est ce que on
va rester six mois un an son point parce
que forcément si faut venir
dodo d'autres entreprises ça va être
quoi la rénovation de bâtiments ce les
entreprises elles vont pas débarquer
excusez moi du jour au lendemain pour
venir s'installer en plus d'une
proposition de reclassement pour chacun
des salariés les syndicats entendent
désormais négocier une prime
il en avait déjà touché une en début
d'année cette fois pour les excellents
résultats du groupe un groupe qui ne
cesse de rationaliser ses usines pour
augmenter sa rentabilité